تشالنجر 2 العمود الفقري لقوه الدبابات في
الجيش البريطاني وهي واحده من اربع دبابات
قتاليه رئيسيه طورتها دول حلف الناتو لخوض
الحروب فهل ستقدر هذه الدبابات على مواجهه
دبابه تي 9 الروسيه احدى افضل دبابات
العالم من حيث الحمايه والتدريع في ساحه
المعركه باوكرانيا مشاهدينا طول دبابات
تشالنجر 2 يتجاوز الاحد 10 مترا ووزنها 62
طنا ونصف دبابه ثقيله الحركه سرعتها تصل
الى 59 كلم في الساعه ويصل مداها الى 450
كلم اما تي 9 فطولها وطولها هيكلها اقل من
سبعه امتار ووزنها اخاف بكثير ويصل الى
نحو 48 طنا من ذخائر والافراد قدره عاليه
على المناوره ع السرعه قصوى تصلوا الى 70
كم في الساعه بينما يصل مداها الى 500 كلم
تشالنجر 2 مشاهدينا دبابه مصممه لمهاجمه
الدبابات الاخرى وتدميرها تحتوي على دروع
ثقيله ومدفع رايسي من عيار
180م باثنين وخمسين قذيفه بالاضافه طبعا
لمدفعين اخرين بمقدار 4000 طلقه فيما
المدفع الرئيسي للدبابه الروسيه فهو من
عيار
125 ملم كمان نشاهد هنا اجمالي الطلقات مع
مدفعين اخرين يبلغ الفين و 2340 طلقه
ومجهزه بصواريخ موجهه مداها خمسه
كيلومترات تتميز تي 9 بالنظام قليل التحكم
في اطلاق النار هنا الدبابه باستطاعتها
البحث عن الاهداف وتعقب هذه الاهداف في
وضع الثبات او الحركه ليلا او نهارا ايضا
كانت
بالعوده مشاهدينا الى تشالنجر هي مصممه
لعبور التضاريس المفتوحه
وتمثلها بذلك الدبابه الروسيه ذات القدره
العاليه على اجتياز الموانع الطبيعيه
[موسيقى]